i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this because we're going to be covering
it live tonight but one of the things
that is expected to uh be shown tonight
at what is as of now the last january 6
committee hearing are videos of trump
trying to record that bizarre speech to
the rioters right after the january 6th
riots and outtakes will be published
tonight during the hearing which will
show donald trump struggling through his
post riot speech the report is that
trump
was visibly struggling with what to say
not wanting to say certain things
clearly trying to
deliver a recorded video about the riots
that would not make trump look like he
was happy about the violence which it
sort of seems like he was but also would
not anger and isolate or alienate his
supporters and those are uh expected to
be
uh shown tonight here's a little bit of
a preview of that from last night on cnn
jeffrey uh the january 6 committee has
snippets of outtakes from trump's tape
message the day after the ride listen to
what this is what congressman adam
schiff told me about it tonight watch
there are people urging him to say
things uh to try to get the the
rioters the attackers to go home uh
there are things that uh they that he
can't be prevailed upon to do and say
not for hours and hours uh and uh and
then ultimately when he does give a
statement still
things he wouldn't say and so
uh you'll have to wait until uh tomorrow
evening to see precisely what that is
we are going to be covering that live
tonight on youtube twitch and facebook i
hope that you will join me i don't have
more to say about it right now we'll let
those snippets speak for themselves
tonight find me on twitter at dpakman